the Joe Rogan experience but for the
aliens um would he think he had a bet if
I if you had a hundred bucks you last
hundred bucks it'sit's hard I if I had a
hundred bucks and we were gonna find out
I'd say I'm leaning more toward just
them no I'm not more towards yes - I
wasn't leaning before that interview I
wasn't though
I wasn't before the documentary that
Jeremy Korbel documentary bob lazar area
51 in flying saucers mm-hmm before that
I was like mostly [ __ ] is that one
is that one available yeah it's great
yeah I'll check that there's a lot of
old Bob Lazar [ __ ] - from the George
Knapp interviews where he goes over the
the details of the craft and he
describes it and explains it and what
[ __ ] knew about element 115 in
the 1990s that's that's that's one of
the big ones that gets me that's one of
the big ones that's like that's a big
red flag that this dude's real this is a
lot who knows but there's a lot that
makes me go mm-hmm I know we do talk
about this all the time but I so [ __ ]
wish Sasquatch was real I'm walking
around I buy all the little like
roadside trinkets and I love that [ __ ]
I wish he was [ __ ] real man it would
be nice it's I mean that's that's one of
the ones I'm like 90% sure you got a
give you always got to give room you
always got to give room for the the
possibility the thing is that people
really believe and then go looking for
it they invest so much time and if they
start going crazy yeah like Survivorman
Les Stroud yes it's gone gone gone gone
it's out there in the woods yeah he's
got a pup tent waiting for Bigfoot not
[ __ ] zippers yeah it's weird man he's
a hundred percent believer now well he
does that for Survivorman Bigfoot show
it was like when I heard a branch snap
cut the corner that's definitely a
Squatch yeah those shows are weird man
because those shows have been on TV like
surviving Bigfoot or Finding Bigfoot
rather so Finding Bigfoot was on TV for
it what eight [ __ ] years they never
found [ __ ] like how the [ __ ] do you keep
her new in that [ __ ] I'm gonna breathe
underwater the show is called breathing
underwater
can you breathe underwater not yet tune
in next week next season though we
try to breathe under will free to the
[ __ ] out y'all just give us an offseason
we'll get this talking these scientists
they're saying no one could breathe
underwater
not yet they don't know [ __ ] us honestly
we south Louisiana we got a guy he
breathes underwater if if there was a
Bigfoot no one be happier than me dead
I'd be right there though I was so
[ __ ] stuck Majesty knit a cage that
cage that I want to see it like in
destiny like the mushrooms trip where
he's like walking and singing with him
Oh Jack Black speaker that's the picture
that's to me Pick of Destiny I would
want to be there I want to want to see
it with my own eyes video I'd be like
man I saw 80-foot tall Donald Trump with
a Hillary Clinton walking through a
post-apocalyptic Philadelphia you can't
you can't prove to me that videos real I
need to see it I would I would [ __ ] my
pants I don't know what I would say
though if I was in the woods and I was
camping and I saw [ __ ] nine foot tall
gorillas I don't know what I would say
you wouldn't I mean if you came I'm not
sure you probably have to yeah cuz you'd
be so you feel so stupid
yeah well puss I mean there's a lot I
mean say there is one out there there's
a lot of [ __ ] artists out there
telling you they saw some [ __ ] you know
a lot of people trying to get some
camera time it can't be one though if
it's gonna be a real thing a living
thing that has to be a living population
of them yeah because primates don't live
that long I don't think there's a
primary that lives any older than humans
we're just we're just way into the ways
we know it doesn't exist mostly exist
yeah as they like to get better and
better like using drones and scanning
the forests and stuff it's getting less
and less likely yeah I used to do that
as a kid that like walk out in the woods
and like look and hope yeah when I was
living in Oregon I was like Hells Canyon
is probably one of the least explored
parts of Oregon hey if he was anyway
he'd be up there you know well there's
some dense ass thick forests in the
Pacific Northwest which is one of the
reasons why I think it's so attractive
yeah because like you think like man
anything could be in here no one knows
like you go outside of Philadelphia or
uh excuse me Seattle when you go into
like you know what is it what's the
mountain out there
what's the sat Helen st. knowns the one
that blew but there's another one that
anyway those big-ass mountains filled
with soup
there's the trees are so dense it's like
a box of q-tips yeah just one up to the
other bang bang bang bang bang and the
forest floor is all pine needles so that
nothing would leave a footprint right
and then you look you look would if you
saw something 30 yards away it could
disappear instantly left right you
wouldn't know where the [ __ ] it is you'd
never find it and it could it could be
out there so I think that also leads to
this this delusional idea that it might
be alive
[Applause]